[تصفيق]
من كان
[موسيقى]
ال
انا
غدا التركيز هو ملغ
أنا أبحث عن هناك أريد أن أرى
الذهب ماريا دا سيلفا تريد صديقتها
لن أذهب لأن اليوم بطل
شباك التذاكر ، أي كان هناك عودة
يقود الصليب مع الهزيمة في الداخل
من الفم واختتمت القوة بخروج الكرة
عن طريق الفم بتقنية كليو بوتافوجو
المقولة قديمة هناك فعلها بشكل جيد للغاية
هو
هولغوين على وسادة
كيفن وجو كول صورة نائب الجزع
dem-rs من فاكتويد مع باربوزا
لم يكن هناك شيء في بورتو فيلهو من هو اليوم
رؤية المستثمر فقط مع قمة قصيرة o
التي أقول طريقنا إليها
الشارع يعني أنه لا يملك
تهدف إلى سرقة من فورة حول
فوز 3-1
هو الأفضل
[موسيقى]
وفقا لضربة البرق ميريل ستريب المحظورة
لا تستخدم هنا فقط من أجل لا شيء يؤثر
إجبار هاميلتون بالترتيب وكرة القدم
أيضا من خلال منصة نقل رأس
خارج وأداء حتى رحلة الملهمة
chapadão منه هو أو سوف يضغط على واحد
تاكو معه في تلك العصابة والتركيز في الشارع
من منتج المعركة الصلبة الذي يدعم
استمعت الفكرة بشكل قاطع
أنا لست عجوز موسيقى الروك أند رول
[موسيقى]
يمكن أن يقول ذلك عندما هزم
الشاعر وايضا الصفقة اغلقت في ذلك الوقت
بواسطة r film يصادف وداع جنين
يمكننا تغطية 01 من الصوت لمناقشة
ملاءمة الإرهاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان من الرائع الاستمتاع بالحديث هناك
أنت تعلم الآن أن الأمر لم يعد كذلك
[تصفيق]